la question que je pose c'est plutôt la
question de l'obligation vaccinale
c'est-à-dire et de l'accès au vaccin
c'est à dire que le vaccin aujourd'hui
alors juste une précision le vaccin ne
permet pas de soigner le vaccin permet
donc de limiter les formes graves de la
maladie et donc les dernières données
scientifiques disponibles montrent que
ça permet également de de limiter la la
transmission donc sa voix latran la
transmission entre personnes donc il ya
à la fois un bénéfice pour les individus
qui seront vaccinés un bénéfice
également pour ceux qui ne seront pas
encore vaccinés en raison du moindre
risque de transmission de ceux qui
seront vaccinés mais effectivement vous
avez raison tant que le vaccin n'est pas
disponible pour tout le monde y aurait
une inégalité qui seraient introduites
donc par ce passeport vaccinale
indépendamment des données de vin qui
s'ajoute en plus des des problèmes de
sécurité informatique est donc pour moi
c'est un peu tôt de parler de cette
question tant que la vaccination n'est
pas accessible à tous parce que là ça
pose de véritables problèmes éthiques
mais la question de l'obligation
vaccinale en revanche me semble être
quelque chose d'important a posé ses
existe en france et donc pour voilà
toute une série de vaccins pour pouvoir
aller enfin mettre son enfant à la
crèche par exemple ou à l'école et je
trouve qu'il ya une question qui est
intéressante qui est posée aujourd'hui
c'est la question de l'obligation
d'actionnaires également pour les
soignants parce qu'on sait qu'il ya
énormément de contamination qui se font
en milieu hospitalier
[Musique]